the NHL has their own version of Victor
wanyama debuting this year so if you
don't know who the NHL's number one
draft pick Connor Bard is here are some
things you need to know although he's
only 18 years old he was named the
future of hockey at 13 he played Junior
Hockey 2 years before he was even old
enough there are only seven other
players to have ever done that you're
probably thinking he's an next Wayne
Gretzky at this point speaking of Wayne
when then 14-year-old Bard received a
phone call from some random California
number he almost didn't pick up and when
he did pick up it was Wayne Gretzky Bard
was almost positive his buddy was just
prank calling him but it wasn't it was
Gretzky calling him to congratulate him
on his success so far can you imagine